hey man do you like fat man I'm Batman
do you like us do you love fat man
Batman would you like to see it like
lies you like booze do you like bars you
like people do you like space come watch
me and Mark do fat man I'm Batman
live in front of actual people at the
scum and villainy Cantina right there on
historic Hollywood Boulevard in
Hollywood California have you ever
wanted to live the Hollywood Life you
ever want to go to a Hollywood bar and
get discovered like [ __ ] Lana Turner
was that was she was it
she's like a Mel's drive-in or whatever
[ __ ] you know but this that's how things
happen Batman on Batman show on
Hollywood Boulevard some casting agent
says you look like Clark Gable and you
wind up in something give that man a
standard rich and famous contract there
himself where herself will actually put
a sash around you and just Clare you a
new star these things could happen
you'll never know unless you go see fat
man I'm Batman live at the scum and
villainy canteen October 10th and
October 17th you could buy tickets right
now right now at C smart calm it's a
good time it's so good if you're like
what am I getting into
go watch the episode we shot at scum and
villainy canteen a couple weeks back
it's like two and a half hour episode
it's up for like 50,000 views too good
[ __ ] time come on out and join us
we're gonna start making this a regular
thing oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah you want
to get your fat man on you want to get
it on live you want to watch me and Mark
talk at each other using words oral all
over each other
fat man I'm Batman live scum and
villainy Cantina Hollywood Boulevard
Hollywood California October 10th
October 17th be there be square yeah
sorry for the mess star trekkin yo we're
gonna boldly go or so many people on
YouTube have gone before and review Star
Trek discovery today on fat man on
Batman
[Applause]
to Batman on Batman welcome to fat man
Batman I'm Kevin Smith
okay so Star Trek discovery is happening
whether you want it to or not and it's
happened in them we're gonna talk about
its new Star Trek show CBS is making it
and they're so proud of it they put it
on their app only did they debut it on
the real channel the the first hour of
the two-hour premiere debuted on CBS
right before we review the quality or
the content or the show itself let's
just talk about this app channel and
using Star Trek as geek bait which is
entirely what it is absolutely there and
now I've seen some people and my Twitter
feed because I put up a picture it's
talking about watching the show you know
and some people were like you know
they're saying by [ __ ] Star Trek but
somebody raised a point of you know
they're just using Star Trek fans to
build their channel but I'm like I
haven't thought about that and you're
right but at the same time it's mutually
beneficial because nobody was gonna make
a new Star Trek show except in this
format right I mean they could because
if you can't want to maybe they're like
look fools you don't know the numbers we
make it Star Trek for years and it
[ __ ] don't work out at the end of the
day so maybe if you want this show bad
enough you'll support this damn app
channel then you can have your Trek let
the premier have you trekking and take
it to the first hour of the premiere
which courts aired on CBS nice job got
nine million viewers which is you know
substantial odds a pretty substantial
premiere because Star Trek hasn't been
on TV in over a decade now the movies
have done really well yeah clearly
there's an audience for this now so what
CBS and paramount are doing is they're
almost like deficit audience building by
we want to do a nap because anybody's
doing a nap what's the thing we can make
people subscribe to nap for Star Trek
nobody's gonna subscribe to this app for
like in C is Los Angeles right that's
not what they're here for
he's got a point so it's it could
absolutely work on broadcast they but
but they're using it as like Julie $8 a
month to watch Star Trek nine nine nine
ninety nine they tried to charge me that
[ __ ] this morning I think I chose $5.99
with a couple commercials take it you
know I wasn't sold is that they call it
the free trial but still they charges if
you if you don't cancel a certain point
so I was like look this is out we got to
go that's how we got to go so before we
dive into the show proper a little bit
about like the CBS app Channel yeah it
looked expensive you know like it looked
expensive like it looked like or I
hadn't thought about until I started
watching I'm like god damn it all these
companies that all want their own
[ __ ] app channels and streaming
content each has to build a player that
they can't just use the Netflix players
can't just use the Hulu player they got
to build their own [ __ ] new player
and that's money you got a spin that's
sinking costs in like tech and IT and
all of that [ __ ] as opposed to I'm
making a show and licensing it to a
network or to a streamer or tour
whatever let them worry about
maintaining the pipes in the backend let
them worry about bandwidth problems
pipes in the backend Star Trek is my
favorite story it's the best Jefferies
tubes you set phasers on fun yes
it's smart business it's it's my
business if what you really want to do
is be a streamer yes
it's smarter business if what you do is
say I have a Star Trek show maybe one of
the most popular franchises in the world
who wants it who's gonna bid for it it's
true what's the highest bidder gonna be
its Hulu just Hulu on it will Hulu spend
will Netflix pen will Amazon spend or
we'll just see do you think they tried I
don't think so I think they were
hell-bent on starting an app and figured
look what we have this is our IP this is
the fill that on Gene Roddenberry's back
we're gonna pick them Roddenberry's
we're making eat them again you know and
then the thing of it is though like a
world planets but like is there is this
the IP that will get you to spend nine
dollars a month to have access to me
personally no but Star Trek fans I mean
we'll see what the subscription numbers
are like and will we ever though that
was my only thought this morning as I
was watching us like how we don't know
if this worked no we won't really and
yes it's like it's none of your [ __ ]
business it's our business you just
watch that's
yeah this is almost more brand
maintenance than financial smart i sat
there tried to pick it apart after or
that tweet like yeah man they are
[ __ ] using the Star Trek fans but
it's Star Trek fans using them right
back you want to Star Trek show this is
how you get it totally now the question
is how bad do you want Star Trek good
you want it so bad that you will do
$8.99 a month
or do you want it so bad that you'll
wait for the entire run to complete and
then subscribe for one month and binge
the [ __ ] out of it or wait until it's on
DVD and buy it now or wait until you
know Alex as well a little venture
eventually go my guess is no everybody
starts getting proprietary yeah totally
I mean I think even Netflix is realizing
that because Netflix is is pushing their
spend towards creating original content
more than licensing old content because
they realize that if everybody is in
this space where everything is
proprietary the only way to the only way
to win this war is to create as opposed
to license and that good think about
that you the listener out there or the
watch or the view or whatever [ __ ]
you're sitting there going like oh
[ __ ] just talk about the show tell me
how much you hate it the Klingons and
[ __ ] like that we'll get in there
alright we're gonna get there simmer
down but this is a clarion call for
those of you who create because what
they what you just said yeah I mean the
the the war for this will be fought with
content and they need they need content
they need you now more than ever in the
history of media making movies making TV
making internets whatever they call that
stuff digital they there they need
[ __ ] content in a big bad [ __ ] way
and so everybody is there producing at a
rate now that's never been seen before
now there's like always wanted to get in
that [ __ ] time now's the time and you
know we may talk in another show about
the bubble that we're currently living
in but yeah but Marc's worried one day
it's gonna stop I told them it is all
gonna stop the end of the world till
then or a lot of 999 apps we're gonna be
paying for its crazy people used to
[ __ ] about my cable bill is $200 I
guarantee you now if you start adding up
all these app channels that you want to
own where you're like a why do you want
to watch that new running watch like I'm
gonna cut the cord [ __ ] you cable
you still got to spend like 50 bucks 60
bucks a month
to get broadband access yes to pipe all
the [ __ ] into your house yes app after
app after app an enable TV or an Apple
TV or Roku whatever it is you're
ultimately spending about $200 a month
for this anyway
maybe they got you money they see be yes
baby they ain't got you money i up you
know what late but that's coming in I I
did think I did not think I would ever I
thought a free trial and cancel the [ __ ]
that being said I kind of I was telling
mark right before we started I was never
be tough to admit on the internet do it
say it I have never been in on the
ground floor on a trek television drew
first certainly not the first 100 few
Star Trek next generation I came into
later on and then the rest of them I
didn't watch so this was the first one
where I'm like I could be a part of this
movies that was a movie guy right so I
could do the movies backwards and
forwards sounds dirty the immense it
sounds like Kirk [ __ ] every different
alien he kept Klingons in the tailpipe
but it's it's I'm not I know the movies
out another shows insanely well and I
came to the shows always late so I was
like maybe I could jump on from day one
and be there for the building of
something I like
Shaniqua niqua plays the Michael Michael
Michael Burnham like in the future
the girls are named after boys my
character who was written for rosario
Dawson what why didn't she do it her
Marvel contract you're [ __ ] me yeah
like that was their first choice wrote
it for her Wow like once once you get
that you're like oh no that's totally
what they were going for it's so I'm
like [ __ ] it I'm not diving so I I
bought the app and now that I'm two
episodes in I thought I was watching one
I know I had to watch to don't thank God
I woke up six in the morning that's when
I was watching this I'm I'm Connie I'm
in I mean that it's interesting in the
and I am a Star Trek fan okay I watched
the premiere encounter at Farpoint
two-parter for next
narration all the way through watch all
of deep space now I watch that too that
was where McCoy was in it right the old
man yeah you just walk it on with crush
data I think it was David Walker okay
carry your crew yes maybe I was on
[ __ ] the ground full see you Shrek
you just gave up yeah I was like worried
[ __ ] where's all the Fighting's like
we're saving that for Star Trek
discovery now as a person that watch a
lot of Trek yes you know they've
definitely they've had battles but it
wasn't ever Star Wars and as much as
like every episode yes the son of a
[ __ ] or yes son of a [ __ ] like they
talk a lot right there's the it was very
much the philosophical version of
science fiction it was if we're
diplomats and emissaries the thing that
a diplomat an emissary wouldn't do was
punch people in the [ __ ] face yeah
all the time I threw that out for the
show yeah this show is about war they
would eventually get there deep space 9
I'm not Worf roof the third Star Trek
show that was not coming the animated
series I don't want to slide any
animated series fans never but classic
Trek next generation Deep Space 9 was
the first show that was created after
Gene Roddenberry died okay and Gene
Roddenberry was all about peace was all
about we figured it out was all about
the conflict that will arise is not one
interpersonally but will be like man
versus nature man versus space man
versus the unknown not man versus man
man versus Tron yeah yeah
Deep Space 9 was ultimately all about
war like it it became a great show it
became a dark show about conflict about
about especially between races about
drug addiction about prison about
prisoners of war about and it was you
know and it's also telling that one of
the key writers in that series was one
more who went over to Bala who would
then take a lot of that to Battlestar
without any of the trappings of the
Federation of just know what happens
when there's an apocalypse when there's
an Armageddon where there's a Holocaust
how do you what there's no Captain Kirk
to save you what do they do
totally you do Battlestar Galactica and
so there's there's their seasons of Deep
Space nine that are all about war and
like big space battles and all that [ __ ]
that you kind of love and watching
discovery it's like ah you know they're
there they're picking and choosing from
the tricks that they like right and kind
of putting in a blender and saying right
we want the exploration we want the
Starfleet doesn't ever fire first we
all that stuff we also want bunches of
space battles we want Klingons weird
Klingons
let's talk about the Klingons because
[ __ ] it's they're the elephant in the
room yeah why did they feel the need to
overcomplicate these characters makeup
effects like I'm just on a production
budget level I'm like this must take
hours yeah to put together all these
[ __ ] clowns who have no movement
whatsoever and then they put them in
these like eighteenth-century looking
things where even in the fight scenes
they were like oh yeah there's no
movement whatsoever it was like eat
yourself but in that where they covered
up like the most handsome man in the
universe you cover them with that [ __ ]
it's crazy it seemed like overdone and
again and what really bugs me is that
you know and this bugs made a first
world war first Federation of Planets
kind of way nice but this takes place
how many years before 10 years before
Kirk and Spock okay we all seen [ __ ]
Klingons in that show
they don't look overly complicated like
this no so how they gonna explain that
[ __ ] and why are their [ __ ] walking
holograms 10 years before [ __ ] Kirk
and and Anthony Michael Hall was one of
them yeah they blow him up spoilers
farmer Ted I mean there was there was
this beaten in when Worf goes to deep
space 9 yeah there's an episode called
trials and tribulations I'm cutting deep
where they time-travel back to the the
Tribble episode of the classic show so
there's been Cisco like [ __ ] Avery
Brooks walking next to William Shatner
and like standing next to Scottie and
it's one of those like super deft
special effects weavings of putting I
want this it's actually really great but
so they have Worf travelling back in
time looking at the Klingons of that day
and then like Worf what the [ __ ]
happened is like we don't talk about it
without ciders like that there is some
in canon reason why
Klingons went from looking like dudes
and like blackface to crazy make up
skull face whatever
well they in this they're like there are
many tribes or call 24 clans of Klingons
clan
there was a very gameofthrones the
element to all the Klingons Game of
Thrones plus like ancient Egypt in a way
and also just unlike aside from the make
up being unnecessarily complicated like
I get it like Klingon is a real language
and [ __ ] like that but why don't you
just confer about October that [ __ ] push
it on his mouth push it out let him
speak English could you imagine this
poor fella got the job playing the lead
went on calling all's friends like I'm
gonna be in Star Trek and then they see
it and I like worry yeah see you and I
don't recognize your voice cuz you not
even speaking English I think it's part
of it was maybe to cover the fact that
those dudes all sounded like space Bane
all the torchbearer
quick comin page language it really is
and so there's Russian sound pretty few
things do except for ballerinas
it was that was something I really and
and I looked normally you'd be like hey
the showing called Klingon Trek it's
Star Trek but they spent all [ __ ] on a
time with the Klingon yeah and gave you
far too much time to be like nope no
those outfits are bad no don't want this
they restrict movement like and and
every time I'm like I will the now
they're gonna switch to English yeah
never and you know not to me the dude is
always gonna make it racial but let me
make a ratio for a second go ahead all
those Klingons are super [ __ ] black
right were they dark to see and there's
a one like albino guy who's the Klingon
from no house who is very clearly going
to be the Klingon who unites everybody
are you kidding yeah he's the guy who
was like remember you and I knew it must
be the one who robbed a bra you're Tuvok
BAE or whatever the [ __ ] his name is is
the albino Klingon dude the one white
Klingon who's gonna be the one who
unites well I mean look here there's
this apart they they were setting up the
one guy to be the savior yep and you
know even in on the spaceship on the
Federation ship what was it the good
shame Joe did not enterprise no they
were like hey man bring him back alive
we
got a breakup I can't kill I'm gonna
show the world that you imprison this
Klingon [ __ ] so they go to get him and
[ __ ] like that and you're like right on
man like this is it he's our main
character mm-hmm and he's got a little
out by nobody yeah they may or may not
be in love we'll see and then all of a
sudden he gets [ __ ] killed uh-huh and
you know he starts going like you got a
you got a beat a leader right so on you
chalky you can do it and it was real and
I mean it's certainly not it was like in
when they were setting it up
he was like you who were born with this
skin color that we all don't like but I
see you as a that's when he said I see
myself and he's the hottest line on a
[ __ ] show I was like I see that too
if you want to switch to Klingon porn
then maybe that makeup will make a lot
of sense those outfits you know I feel
like maybe it's one of those well listen
we have a black lead to the show Sonique
ooh Martin green in this particular
two-parter Michelle Yeoh is the captain
of the ship like we bought ourselves all
the diversity so here's what we're doing
over here
remember that episode of Mad Men where
the guy from like season one or two came
back and he was a Harry Krishna and he
wanted Harry the guy in the office to
like take his he wrote an episode of
Star Trek and he's like I need you to
get this to gene Rhonda and so when he
read the script like they you know they
were asking other characters in the show
like what was it how was it and you know
he was just like he was a planet where
you know it basically it was a
black/white allegory and you know it was
like painful you could kind of see it's
nothing this isn't that bad no and by
the way Star Trek did the painful
black/white allegory episode with Frank
Gorshin yeah that's one half black and
one half white yes like we don't want
the people who have white on their left
sides we want them with white on the
right side because race you guys so
they've always handled race on that show
they always have and sometimes more
definitely than others I mean there's
there's a lot of really great stuff in
next generation talking about data as an
artificial person and what it means to
be a how you declare something worth
respect with rights and like the idea of
an artificial race of beings who would
probably be if you don't grant
their manhood they would become a slave
race and you have to make that decision
as a civilization do you want to be the
kind that has slaves in the kind who
doesn't and the Federation doesn't and
it's exactly like a legal episode where
they're in a courtroom and they're
trying to decide whether that's measured
a man I think whether data has rights
whether dude has rights where whether
data has the right to decide for himself
what he wants his life to be Wow i man
[ __ ] you like you keep dropping better
episode Sheree picks overdose for you
there's a lot of drag in the middle
screen junkies just did a Star Trek The
Next Generation Amish Trail so there was
an episode where Beverly Crusher [ __ ]
a ghost yeah okay so back to this show
back to the show so they hear that they
you know they did something with the
main character that goes against what
Star Trek or what the Federation stands
for number one she attacks her
commanding officer and friend like with
the Vulcan nerve pinch and she's not a
Vulcan she's a human child who was
raised by Spock's father
Sarek yes so I thought and so of course
never have they mentioned her ever and
he calls her his ward at 1:00 yeah 50
years of Star Trek has Spock never
mentioned oh yeah I got a black sister I
have a half-sister or anything like that
exactly or my father raised award before
I was born and you know she had a whole
bunch of adventures but you know Kirk's
way more interesting don't talk about
that the budget they need a lot of money
Klingons and their version look
expensive okay so she takes out not
kills but takes out her commanding
officer and wants to fire upon the
Klingon Empire because it's something
CEREC told her he did back in the day
he's like that's how Klingons you know
right you know like race needs a sort of
you gotta slap him across the punch him
in the nose yes
so you know she's like that's it and she
goes to try to make that happen but the
Michelle Yeoh plays her captain she's
number one the killer number one is
right
right his name is Michael which I guess
isn't Mike you know the chick who's on
the walton serve the mom
her name's Michael I guess it's not that
weird yeah I mean it's mostly weird odd
could have gone anywhere he go with
Michael no I'm no writer buried with an
IE you buy me there pretty good see she
came up at berry Burnham take it away so
she winds up at the end of the
two-parter well during the two-parter
she like I wouldn't say she instigates a
war she's almost tried to prevent it
right she did what she thought was right
to save lives and to avert a war
you've got to ultimately start a war but
everybody thinks it seems like from the
trailer coming up and that she started
the war she becomes like persona non
grata in the in the galaxy people like
she [ __ ] started the war with the
claimant right she also did kind of kill
a Klingon on her little walkabout so
maybe that's why they said you started
the war right like she accidentally bat
left so clinging on through the chest
yeah which was kind of yeah I mean it's
just like she threw on her thrusters and
also they cut to a shove like her
pompano and then a [ __ ] knife comes
out his back holy [ __ ] in space nobody
could see that kind of velocity so she
at the end of the episodes wanted to
make up the pilot Connor goes to jail
and we don't even meet Jason Isaacs nope
who's I guess in the next step he's the
captain of the actual discovery we never
set foot on the discovery represented -
yeah somebody says the word discover
that's about it I think so we read we
are here to discover not to fight I
thought I thought I thought
Shaniqua was better on Game of Thrones
but that's not her performance again
Walking Dead 2 shows that I was and and
it's not because I think that it was
weird cuz I watch the whole episode
going like autor giving her you know
they're giving her gobbledygook science
fictiony stuff to say and she's got to
say as a Vulcan
as a human approximating a Vulcan yeah
like I didn't appreciate her performance
until that little bit where they
flashback to her first day bang yes
mission Joe Michelle Yeoh and Sarah Kerr
like well we think she needs to be back
with her people we feel like you're the
one to
to help guide her back into humanity and
then watching her be all stilted and
logic and emotion free there contrasted
with where you pick her up when she
feels like she's got a sense of humor
and she's integrated and like she's
doing she's doing a lot in contrast
without that contrast it just looks kind
of flat interesting yeah she hopefully
they let her be yeah like get some
shades to it yeah let her be her but
again not like she's oh it's unwatchable
she's great but she just she was well I
just came off a watch and I [ __ ]
binge on last season of Walking Dead and
she ends last season she's in the season
finale and her like going out episode is
strong also involves flashbacks so you
know I was just coming off of that and
then all of a sudden this you know it's
a lot of flying around but she does she
doing good Michelle yeah enjoy her while
you got her yeah seriously it's not for
very long kind of in out is that uh
wasn't it Doug Jones yeah
Hellboy mm-hmm playing whatever that Abe
Sapien in space like this creature who
was bred to be able to sense essentially
or a space cow right he talked about
like my planet you know shit's binary
there's predator and prey and we were
raised to be like eaten oh [ __ ] he's a
space cow but he's like but our people
understand fear like we can sense death
coming yeah that's like an I sense it
deeply yeah or whatever he's kind of
always scared yeah but like it's it's
Cowardly Lion of the show it's weird
that you know a show a Star Trek show
usually begins with here's your crew yes
here's who you are going to follow for
the rest of his show this begins with
here's the captain of a ship we're not
going to be on again who by the way gets
stabbed in the chest so spoiler again
Michelle Yeoh is not in the show
going forward anymore yeah the Shan Joe
the ship that she's on is not the ship
we're gonna be following no I'm assuming
Doug Jones will leave and go to a zombie
trailer so it looks like he's gonna show
up there so like we're not invested in
anyone
else on the spaceship at all what I was
thinking by the time I got to the end of
the second episode I'm like oh how
interesting to create a pilot where only
one person is really kind of going
forward yeah like you know I think maybe
that's where we spend all the money on a
ship that is not gonna be a standing set
on characters who were never gonna see
again that's the point mark was saying
before we started he was going like they
didn't you know show any rooms on this
that maybe three rooms and that's why
because they're like we're never we're
gonna blow the [ __ ] up never come back
it's kind of small to me it felt you
know it's like we're we opened on this
other planet this dustbowl planet kind
of cool whatever you get up to the ship
we see a couple of rooms you see the
captains quarters in the bridge and
that's it we spend a lot of time when
it's Klingon ship and a little bit of
time in space like it felt small spend a
lot of time reading folks yeah and I was
watching it on a friend of mine had the
streaming app the first night of the
debut they got hammered with traffic
needless to say so slows down the stream
would just fracture every now and again
and fractured subtitle reading is the
worst kind of subtitle reading because
you hear them speaking but it's the the
still image on the screen like I don't
know it's whatever I feel like I can't
read I can't go forward unless I know
Klingon that's your fault for being a
Star Trek fan and not knowing how to
speak Klingon I am sorry I did not read
Hamlet in the original Klingon yeah I am
gonna continue watching it you know I
how many episodes we have um I think
it's ten that's it I think it's ten what
are they gonna put on that [ __ ] app
for the rest of it would you like to see
every episode of NCIS ever made what am
i my mother no how about the CSIS
there's 15 of those yes I can watch
young Sheldon at my leisure mmm so what
are all the CBS shows going away from
Hulu I think they will I think I don't
know if they're gone yet but I think
they will all of the Star Trek shows
will be on the CBS app they they still
have a deal with Netflix through 2019 I
think for Star Trek but and then it's
all going to CBS it's all going to CBS
at everyone's getting proprietary in
building walls all right
everyone's calling home their IP me like
[ __ ] you towards Attar's
it's weird that if discovery is
discovery and I think the good fight are
the spinoff from the good way that's
also CBS that's also CBS all access
those are the only two really for now
app only shows so and everything else on
CBS is you know it's a procedural it's a
crime procedural that your mom watches
you think your mom's gonna download CBS
all access you think your mom's a
streamer if I put it my mom's a streamer
or she goes to the streaming parties
drops her keys in the [ __ ] bowl she's
like streaming all over me I'm single
she's 72 I was John a stiix with the
ribbon streaming all over the face neck
and chest I
I'll put it out if I put on her phone
she would watch it yeah yeah I got to do
it for her that's the thing I guarantee
you she'd be like oh my god tiger you've
changed my life and once again you're
the greatest son because I put an app on
it my mom is not going to buy herself
download CBO cell access and then watch
it on her phone she would want it on our
television Bible tell evasion they fit
for this I feel like that's maybe their
big problem is that the de CES is
audience is not a streaming audience Oh
interesting so they're counting on us
nerds to be the audience that comes to
their apt for Gen X and the Millennials
will save them they hope they hope not
gen why they're not invested in this
okay like skin ain't got no skin and
Star Trek game I'm texting emoji
Greatest Generation is still trying to
figure out why the clock on their VCRs
[Laughter]
by making fun of the fact thank you for
punching all the Nazis at one point but
hey but hey press the little button on
the right now that says blinking time
Ari ah man I'm gonna keep watching we'll
check back in with this show from time
to time so as things develop because
honestly like the trailer for the for
the next episode or coming this season
like almost looks like a completely
different show than we just watch yeah I
think it is a completely different show
because Bryan Fuller who was the initial
show in her left the program so do you
think that they did Bryan's pilot and
the rights to part of the like
so what are we gonna do now and put her
in jail Oh
Star Trek Discovery space show I don't
believe it is I believe it's one of
those jason isaacs says I've got an eye
for talent speaking in an American
accent that doesn't really work but I've
got an eye for talent so I want you on
my ship because you got a thing because
you are paid the most in the cast here
are the number one of the gun yeah I saw
the gall sheet you better be on this
ship going to jail and I bet you at some
point you're the captain of this ship
not yet though well Michelle Yeoh said I
you know I think you should be right
captain one day she was like really are
you sure so I guess by the end of the
season right they'll finally pay that
off like jason isaacs will die in a hail
of bullets like you're the captain now
we're there it's done clip that out
thrown on the app channel those are just
men that's for free there it is man
we reviewed or talked about Star Trek
and we're gonna keep talking about damn
it for all of my problems I kind of
liked it the man is saying my honestly
my biggest problem was like was one of
logic which is and you know I guess
maybe as a guy was not like who hasn't
watched every episode of Star Trek shows
I shouldn't have this point of view but
if in 10 years
the Klingons look like the Klingons look
like on TV when they first did this show
why you doing this overly complicated
[ __ ] makeup job which just on a pure
production level I just sat there going
what a waste of time
yeah like you got to do all those
makeups you talked about all I mean you
know what's good whoever has put this
[ __ ] on and the the prosthetics artists
make it a killing oh yeah goes for them
and good that somebody's employing
people to do special effects makeup you
know as opposed to like CG and [ __ ] but
heavens like spend the money elsewhere I
mean like it and if especially if you've
got to come up with a story right here
yeah a story reason why they go from
looking like dudes in blackface to Worf
make that thing part of the story yeah
about that could be the pilot or make it
like that's why the Klingons are so
[ __ ] pissed off at the federal you
don't look the same or you changed our
looks maybe it's a kind of like you do
the Sneetches story this star upon Mars
action shows up on
on planet Wharf no yeah Klingon planning
and so some go like normal looking and
some go extreme Yahoo so you can do that
crossover Seuss audience and the Trek
audience World War sous-sous Trek we're
gonna keep watching and we'll check back
in indeed but that's all we're gonna say
for now
Star Trek's back kids here's the olive
oil I will say this there are key
moments every key moment that made me
choked up and I did glass over maybe two
or three times here in the show was a
callback to something familiar like in
the beginning when they're on the desert
planet and she's linked I found I had
made it you know I I made us a star they
pull back and you see the Federation
symbol I was like there was another
moment to I think what's Eric was just
like live long and prosper
so they'll get you every time with you
know Star Trek deep cut not even deep
cuts main cuts greatest it's like
[ __ ] polls and porn but more that I
would say yes yes let's let's hit the
grace notes ten years earlier you know
we're gonna run into a young Kirk at one
point I mean we kind of need to yeah we
better which respond doing give me the
pine kid why not
there it is man fat man I'm Batman
talk about starchy carry on brand I'm
Kevin Smith I'm in on Vulcan [ __ ] it
there's a writer there we got it
give him a signal fat man on vote can
now back to a two shot fat man on Vulcan
for fat man on Vulcans I became it's me
I'm Mark Barnard tune in next episode
same bat-time same bat-channel SModcast
I come or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
live long and prosper
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]